[Music]
it's a beautiful year for all marvel
fans after the year began with
spider-man no way home already being one
of the best mcu movies in the movie
theaters we expect after the first
images of doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness nothing less but
that's not the end of it thor is also
finally getting his long-awaited fourth
solo movie with thor 4 love and thunder
we are still waiting for the first
trailer but based on the cast and other
sources we can already say quite a lot
about the movie who will be the next
villain who will return to the big
screen we have dealt with all these
questions and summarized the answers for
you in this video but be warned the
video may contain one or two spoilers
for the mcu
the movie will be set in the middle of
phase four and is most likely to be
released on july 8 2022 in us movie
theaters chronologically it is set
between doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness and black panther
wakanda forever the events will of
course take place after end game
although it will be interesting to see
if they take place before guardians of
the galaxy vol 3 or after as we saw at
the end of avengers and game thor goes
on a journey with the asgardians of the
galaxy to protect the universe from
whatever thereby already comes the first
squirrels between star-lord and him over
the question of who the captain is since
the guardians will definitely play a
role in though 4 it remains exciting
when exactly the storyline will be set
quite a lot is already known about the
cast first the filming was already
completed in june 2021 in australia and
they have already been some photos
leaked on twitter and similar sites
secondly marvel published a few things
through official media channels if you
look at the list of names we should
brace ourselves for quite something
who would have thought chris hemsworth
of course has the role of the god of
thunder but also his love jane foster is
back on the big screen after her
break-in thought 3. this time however
natalie portman has a special role after
director taika waititi gave her the
mighty hammer mjolnir at comic con 2019
it is certain that she won't be only the
shy scientist any longer but that she
will become mighty thor the two are
supported not only by the complete
guardians of the galaxy but also by the
new leader of asgard the valkyrie who
has been in the mcu since ragnarok she
is again played by tessa thompson also
jaime alexander as lady siff shotgun as
craiglin and of course whitehead himself
as the whimsical cork are back in the
game
it is also certain that there will be a
few cameo appearances like they have
been in thor ragnarok any fans were
astonished when in a small plane asgard
suddenly met daemon as loki sam nilas
odin and chris brother luke hemsworth
appeared as thor they are getting
supported by melissa mccarthy who has
been hired to play the evil sister hera
in love and thunder we are already
looking forward to this scene also
confirmed is russell crowe as zeus but
whether this role is to be taken
seriously or if it's just an easter egg
for the fans is unfortunately not known
yet
it's been quite a long time since we got
a scene in a superhero movie but now
it's finally time again christian bale
has been confirmed as the villain in
thor 4. if he can be half as convincing
as he was in the batman the dark knight
series we can definitely look forward to
some great acting he will embody gore
the godbutcher we will have a close look
at the whole story of gore in more
detail at a later point because he has
connections to many characters in the
mcu which we have already met it's
exciting to note here that after the
dark knight rises bale has actually
never wanted to take part in a comic
book adaption again he thinks the genre
is too boring and he always describes
wearing the costume as well let's call
it constricting however taiko was hitti
persuaded him with his charm and above
all a very good script to reconsider his
decision
the ancient gods of our earth will also
play a role two of them are already
confirmed the before mentioned zeus
played by russell crowe and the goddess
bastard played by akosia sabbat while
zeus in the comic stands in connection
to odin and asgard bastard is a goddess
of ancient egypt and is set in wakanda
so gore seems to be targeting not only
gods that we already know maybe thanks
to bastet there will be a bridge to
wakanda forever which will be released
in november this year
it is not yet known whether tom
hiddleston will play a part as loki
again what is certain is that the loki
of the original timeline is dead however
as we know another one was able to
escape with a tesseract and even got his
own series on disney plus we would
definitely be happy to see the two
brothers unite even if the loki from the
other timeline has not yet been as
purified as his dead other self
the mighty thorline will play an
important and big role in the upcoming
movie in it jane foster falls ill with
breast cancer and because of her deeds
pronounced worthy of carrying the hammer
mjolnir it is suspected that she get
cancer due to her contact with the
aether the more she uses her newly
acquired powers the worse the tumors
inside her become white hitti thinks
that this approach of the comics is very
interesting but he has not yet confirmed
that he will use it in the movie how
does she obtain the hammer the mjolnir
which we saw in handgame was finally
brought back into his line by captain
america one theory is that we're not
dealing with the jane foster of the old
movies but that she comes from another
timeline this would fit very well into
the new multiverse after all we already
got to see several versions of the
superheroes in spider-man away home and
in the trailer for doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness
another important role in the movie is
supposed to be the love stories of
course the first thing that comes to
mind is the romance between thor and
jane but there are more and more voices
that say the wild valkyrie embodied by
tessa thompson finally finds her love
even if her sexuality has not yet been
exactly illuminated so far we do know
that she's one of the lgbtq plus
characters in the mcu so it's possible
that there could be a romance with the
new jane or with lady sif
now to the villain gore the god butcher
he was only introduced in the comics in
2013 and is since then one of the most
dangerous opponents of thor gorill lived
on a very religious planet when his
parents died in an accident he renounces
the gods and goes into exile when he
then learns that such beings actually
exist but that they did not help to
protect his family he swears bloody
revenge he wants to perpetrate his
revenge with his powerful sword all
black this was created a long time ago
by the evil god null with it he beheaded
one already known to as celestial the
one from whose head nowhere was born
then with the power of the sword and of
the celestial he created the symbiotes
we know from venom noah was stranded on
the planet of gore when he learned that
he was a god he killed him with his own
sword and set off on his journey it is
conceivable that he hunts the ancient
gods of the earth and that they then
turn to asgard in need of help odin no
longer rules there but his air still
exists by the way a connection between
gore and mighty thor does not exist in
the comics why titty can therefore give
free reign to his creativity
as often mentioned before taika waititi
is again screenwriter director and actor
in one like this he also achieved great
success in the last part thor ragnarok
and made it the most successful movie in
the series to date after the current
production had to be postponed again and
again due to the ongoing situation
filming started on january 26 2021 in
the fox studios in australia in sydney
under the working title the big salad
particularly exciting is the camera
technology with which the new movie was
shot in this stagecraft technology is
used which was already used in the
disney series the mandalorian instead of
standing in front of a green screen the
actors are standing in front of led
video walls where the environment is
displayed on one of the advantages of
this is that the actors can actually see
their surroundings unlike with a green
screen and can thus better empathize
with their role taika white hitti and
chris hemsworth also allowed themselves
a little joke and posted the so-called
first official poster of the movie which
shows well only them on social media
hemsworth wrote about it saying that
they had to really tightly calculate the
budget for the thor love and thunder
poster but that the message is clear
lots of love and lots of thunder
at the end of the video we have some fun
facts for you about the production for
example thor with his fourth solo movie
is now the only mcu character which can
show off so many standalone movies
the cast includes five oscar winners
christian bale matt damon natalie
portman taika whitehead and russell
crowe with balon crow they have already
three actors after michael keaton
switched from dc to marvel it will be
the 29th movie of the marvel cinematic
universe chris hemsworth who is already
playing the role of thor for the 8th
time achieved with 105 kilograms his
largest physique to date for this movie
just to maintain the achieved mass he
had to eat eight times a day
so enough from us now it's time for your
opinion how hyped are you for the new
thor movie we can hardly wait for the
first trailer which you will of course
see here on our channel as soon as it is
released after all ytd said that it will
probably be the best mcu movie ever are
you still missing someone in the current
cast that you would like to see and what
do you think about the plot write us in
the comments and if you liked our video
please don't forget to give it a thumbs
up see you next time
[Music]
you